what there was that nice oh well you
don't see that every day
oh we've missed an opportunity we could
have done this like ali-a or something I
would have got mental at that can we go
back in time please
I want to have a go at doing this as
ali-a oh my god oh my god I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die
[ __ ] trainer oh come on I can do it
this time
although and welcome to PlayStation
grenade I'm hoping I don't die straight
up spawn this time this intro is taking
me forever oh it's all good
we're all good we're all good we're all
good oh yeah just just three thanks
gents I appreciate it so I I don't play
enough videogames and I want to change
that now what did he go so each week I
plan on uploading a video probably
fortnight for a while and switch that up
as I go along and just have more fun
with video games I like where did he go
come on last guy I'll finish the
sentence in a moment last guy here he is
whoa kills I didn't die on my
introduction I'm so happy yeah let's
play more video games okay two squads
two squads landed but where did they go
ho he's going to the gas station come
and save your friend come on come and
save your friend
terrible I'm getting shot in the back
and this guy in the groin come on oh oh
are we memeing what do we wait a sec one
sec I'll get involved and get involved
here we go let's mean together
who needs bullets okay that entire squad
is on its way so we're going to fight
will this work how the hell did not hit
the wall don't question it
it's fought night logic do you think
they will find me oh this is tense I'm
actually a little bit nervous nervous
I'm actually a little bit nervous if I
could speak be a miracle here we go here
we go here we go can he see me ah
perfect hiding place behind the teddy
bear
what I would do for that shotgun now
let's do this here we go one
that was the Wukong from earlier the one
that snapped by the bloody gas station
got damaged season 8 well done guy
dancing in a little house is it because
you're out the builds I'm going nowhere
but are you asking to live no way by the
way this is how you dance yeah let's
just pretend that didn't happen
I know you're down there somewhere oh I
cannot aim that is a nice trip look at
that that is a lovely house here's a new
rule if their house has a roof on it we
can't kill them we have to go attack
somebody else like this guy perfect
timing boss you need a roof need a
pyramid on your roof you almost made it
back to your friend
hang on the guy with the room can you
believe this skill of this chap he knows
to build houses right we'll leave him
alone
run away right you stay in your Hut mate
I'm gonna protect you I will
counter-sniper I'm terrible how was your
little oh you got a little doll
oh that's so adorable look at his dog I
said it's now there's no roof on your
building remember I can shoot you are
you sniping from how you dude in your
Hut mate okay any new skills anything
you can do this different in any way I
can do windows what a guy what ik I'm
really sorry fellow I need to finish
this I'm gonna get pushed by one of
these squads and I need to heal fast
I'm very sorry sir you are my favorite
ever spot my player here we go I look
he's behind there what would Jesus do
hello probably use a hunting oh yeah
yeah here we go ready for this oh thanks
Jesus that's cuz Jesus Christ is my
friend he's got friends this is fun I
quite like high ground
okay okay I get it right
poke your heads let's end this you know
where I am I know where you are
let's snipe come on fella I'm up for
this someone let's do this come on come
on come on come on two hours late tail
come you know what I've had enough it's
okay I won't go for your friend okay
okay yeah he's resting his res damn I
want your friends oh right
let's see if that guy can get in this
circle come on dude you got this where's
he going we need some sort of flu bad
bad flute playing over this like them
see the Titanic one I don't want to hit
you I want to hit your builds you've
gotta be the circle come on you've got
to do this
[Music]
come on you're so close you are so close
to have faith in you you got this bro
come on good
Oh what you almost made it that was
anticlimactic and my heart will go on
um do I just die now because I've
completely forgot what game mode were
playing so me and 20 spectators just
sitting around waiting to die what can I
say except you're dead I don't play the
game mode he's be headed straight are
you hostile you legend I would get you a
weapon and we catch this man oh shoot in
fact I'll keep this weapon what are you
still there here's a weapon for you come
and take it no art that we teaming which
on duty me Josh a to 3:09 we've got this
whoever you are let's stick together you
put pressure on al chi-chi's night thing
well play Josh a two three oh nine Josh
I think we might be the dream team let's
do this boss Josh bogey bogey 12:00
o'clock
taking him down shin snipe chin tonight
that's brilliant work Josh let's kid
this going Joshy snugged another one yes
you're awesome
let me get involved I feel like I'm
doing the 15 yeah just
we know how to do the fortnight come on
[Music]
Josh twelve seconds later Josh a two
3:09 I'll remember these moments we had
together I'm too low too low dad god
damn it god of course is somebody
already up there yeah I love my life
hang on he might be a proper default
even more default E than me this is in
turn broken
Oh keep so you just keep sweet
God pro strats bro pro strats let's wait
for his friend to kill himself on that
trap you shall see it's so good hey it's
a PlayStation default which is looking
out the veranda Oh No
[Music]
no no I don't do 90s I'm never gonna do
90 in my life I'll wait over here and
you'll do what everybody does is good at
building come out of your comfort zone
and get give me a free headshot come on
honey it's that rain down these
predictions hey you got to the end
thanks very much for watching if you did
get all the way to the end write in the
comments ali-a is better than ninja and
I shall try and reply to you also we
always finish with a dance now
celebrating those people who are kind
enough to use my code and amaru in the
fort night shop these guys have used it
over the last two weeks thank you very
much I salute you you're all against to
me if you'd like your name to be on
screen in one of these videos please get
in touch on Twitter my name is Adam
grenade over there and send a picture of
something you bought in the shop using
my code anyway it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you for your time I'll
see you again next time